well the federal government has
designated the american red cross to
co-lead mass care during disasters that
includes providing shelters food and
emergency supplies
in texas it has helped put more than 32
thousand people
in shelters the organization and its
partners have served more than a hundred
and eighty thousand meals and snacks
since the storm began
more than fifteen hundred volunteers are
on the ground
gail mcgovern is the president and ceo
of the american red cross she joins us
now from the texas red
cross volunteer command center in austin
good morning to you gail i know you've
got quite the assignment ahead of you
but at this point do the available
resources
meet the demand that you're seeing
well we have as you said 1500 volunteers
on the ground and more
on the way but as you've also reported
there are additional evacuations people
are presenting in shelters
the need is enormous and we've had an
outpouring of support
and a lot of people that are interested
in volunteering
as you said as of tuesday night we've
served 180
000 meals and snacks people are just
showing up at the shelters and the
challenges have been
incredible just getting supplies in
when all these roads have been flooding
have
have been unbelievable and the heroics i
mean we
we were bringing volunteers and city
dump trucks so they could get through
the water we have these high water
vehicles now from the department of
defense
um 20 of them that are bringing supplies
into the shelters
and gail the donation really go ahead
finish
finish no i was just going to say it's
really been a challenge
well i have to say the donations are
pouring in help us understand take us
through the donation process
say someone donates a hundred dollars
how much of that is going to go
to the harvey victims because they're
saying look i want to help the harvey
victims
i'm so moved there are some concerns
that some of that money
goes to red cross overhead red cross pr
so how much of that hundred dollars
actually goes to the harvey victims
that people want to help well
on average 91 cents
of every dollar that we spend goes to
our services and we are really proud of
the fact that we keep
our overhead low and people that are
designating money
for victims of hurricane harvey that
money
will be used for the people that were
impacted by hurricane harvey
we are taking great care to make sure
that we're great stewards of our donors
dollars
so 91 will go to harvey when you say our
services i don't know if that means red
cross services
or the money that's going to the harvey
victims
uh it's red cross services that are
going so
things like food things like supplies
things like
clean up kits and depending on
the level of financial support that we
get we'd also like to give
financial support to the victims as well
but we are going to make sure that every
designated dollar that
is going to this storm is used
appropriately
and like i said on average 91 cents goes
to our services
and we're really proud of that now gail
i'm sure you're sure
aware of some of the stories that say 25
of the money has gone to
overhead some people are out there on
social media saying
gosh that's way too much you've got to
donate to other organizations i'm sure
that doesn't sit well with you well
you know they can take a look at our
financial statements they can see
what our overhead is and
i can tell you that i am really proud of
the fact that we're good stewards of our
donors dollars
and i know how these gifts
are are given i understand the
generosity of the american public
the need is so great and people just
always step up for us
and we take that responsibility very
very seriously
okay how much has been raised so far and
how much you're trying to get
well the need is enormous i mean you've
seen the visuals
it's um it's really incredible and we
are going to be at it for a very
very long time in terms of what we've
raised it's literally changing by the
hour
um
sometime next week we'll be able to give
you a good idea of how much money we've
raised because it's changing very
rapidly
all right gail mcgovern thank you very
much for joining us this morning